De hecho, estamos prosperando.
Y esto gracias a que fuimos bendecidos
con reyes fuera de serie.
Nuestros monarcas ilustrados han trabajado sin descanso
para desarrollar el país,
equilibrando cuidadosamente el crecimiento económico
con el desarrollo social, la sustentabilidad ambiental
y la preservación cultural,
todo en el marco del buen gobierno.
A este enfoque holístico del desarrollo lo denominamos
"Felicidad Interna Bruta", o FIB.
Allá por los años 70,
nuestro cuarto rey célebremente proclamó que en Bután
la Felicidad Interna Bruta (FIB) es más importante que el PIB.
(Aplausos)
Desde entonces,
todo el desarrollo de Bután se guía por la FIB,
una visión pionera que tiene como objetivo
mejorar la felicidad y el bienestar de nuestro pueblo.
Es más fácil de decir que de hacer,
sobre todo si representamos una de las economías más pequeñas del mundo.
Todo nuestro PIB es menor a USD 2000 millones.
Sé que muchos de los presentes tienen más que eso...
(Risas)
en forma individual,
más que toda la economía de mi país.
Nuestra economía es pequeña,
pero ahora se pone interesante.
La educación es completamente gratis.
Todos los ciudadanos tienen garantizada la educación primaria gratuita,
y quienes trabajan arduamente reciben universidad gratis.
La salud también es completamente gratis.
Consulta médica, tratamiento médico, medicinas:
todo proporcionado por el Estado.
Administramos esto
porque usamos nuestros recursos limitados con mucho cuidado,
y porque somos fieles a la misión central de la FIB:
el desarrollo con valores.
Nuestra economía es pequeña, y debemos fortalecerla.
El desarrollo económico es importante,
pero ese desarrollo económico no puede socavar nuestra cultura única
ni nuestro ambiente prístino.
Hoy nuestra cultura florece.
Seguimos celebrando nuestro arte y arquitectura,
la comida y los festivales,
los monjes y los monasterios.
Y sí, celebramos nuestro traje nacional, también.
Por eso puedo lucir mi gho con orgullo.
Este dato es curioso:
están en presencia del bolsillo más grande del mundo.
(Risas)
Empieza aquí,
atraviesa la espalda,
y aparece por dentro por aquí.
En este bolsillo
almacenamos toda clase de artículos de uso personal,
desde teléfonos y billeteras
hasta iPads, archivos de oficina y libros.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Pero a veces...
a veces incluso una carga preciosa.
Nuestra cultura florece,
pero también nuestro ambiente.
El 72 % de mi país se encuentra cubierto de bosques.
Nuestra Constitución exige que como mínimo
el 60 % de la superficie de Bután permanezca
como reserva forestal para siempre.
(Aplausos)
Nuestra Constitución,
esta constitución,
nos exige reserva forestal.
Por cierto, nuestro rey usó esta constitución
para imponernos la democracia.
Ya ven, nosotros, el pueblo, no queríamos democracia.
No la pedimos, no la exigimos,
y, desde luego, no luchamos por ella.
En cambio, nuestro rey nos impuso la democracia
incluyéndola en la Constitución.
Pero fue más allá.
Incluyó disposiciones de la Constitución
que le dan poder a las personas para destronar al rey,
y disposiciones que requieren que el rey se jubile a los 65 años.
(Aplausos)
De hecho, ya tenemos un rey jubilado:
nuestro rey anterior, el Gran Cuarto,
se retiró hace 10 años
en la cima de su popularidad.
Tenía 51 años en ese momento.
Así que como decía,
el 72 % del país está cubierto de bosques,
y todo el bosque es prístino.
Por eso somos uno de los pocos
sitios de biodiversidad global que quedan en el mundo,
y por eso somos un país neutral en emisiones de carbono.
En un mundo amenazado por el cambio climático,
somos un país neutral en emisiones de carbono.
Y eso es muy importante.
De los 200 y pico países en el mundo de hoy,
parece que somos el único
neutral en emisiones de carbono.
En realidad, eso no es del todo exacto.
Bután no es neutral en emisiones.
Bután es negativo en emisiones.
Todo el país genera 2,2 millones de toneladas de dióxido de carbono,
pero los bosques secuestran más de tres veces esa cantidad,
por lo que somos un sumidero neutro de carbono
por más de cuatro millones de toneladas de CO2 al año.
Pero eso no es todo.
(Aplausos)
Exportamos la mayor parte de la electricidad renovable
que generamos con nuestros caudalosos ríos.
Hoy, la energía limpia que exportamos
compensa unos seis millones de toneladas de CO2 en nuestro vecindario.
Para el 2020, exportaremos suficiente electricidad
para compensar 17 millones de toneladas de CO2.
Y si aprovechásemos la mitad de nuestro potencial hidroeléctrico,
y estamos trabajando en ello,
la energía limpia, ecológica, que exportamos
compensaría unos 50 millones de toneladas de CO2 al año.
Eso es más CO2 que lo que genera toda la ciudad de New York al año.
Así que en nuestro país, somos un sumidero neto de carbono.
Hacia el exterior, compensamos carbono.
Y eso es importante.
Ya ven, el mundo se calienta,
el cambio climático es una realidad.
El cambio climático afecta a mi país.
Nuestros glaciares se derriten,
provocando inundaciones repentinas y aludes,
lo que a su vez provoca desastres y destrucción en el país.
Hace poco estuve en ese lago.
Es impresionante.
Así era hace 10 años,
y así era hace 20 años.
Hace 20 años ese lago no existía.
Era un glaciar sólido.
Pocos años después, un lago similar
penetra sus presas
y causa estragos en los valles.
Esa destrucción fue producto de un lago de glaciar.
Tenemos que lidiar con 2700 de ellos.
La idea es esta:
mi país y mi pueblo no han hecho nada
para contribuir al calentamiento global,
pero ya somos los más afectados por sus consecuencias.
Y para un país pequeño y pobre, de montaña, sin salida al mar,
eso es muy difícil.
Pero no vamos a quedarnos cruzados de brazos sin hacer nada.
Lucharemos contra el cambio climático.
Por eso hemos prometido neutralidad de emisiones de carbono.
Primero lo prometimos en 2009
durante la COP 15 de Copenhague,
pero nadie lo notó.
Los gobiernos estaban tan ocupados discutiendo entre ellos
culpándose mutuamente por el cambio climático,
que cuando un pequeño país levantó la mano para anunciar:
"Prometemos la neutralidad permanente en emisiones de carbono",
nadie nos oyó.
A nadie le importó.
El pasado diciembre, en París,
en la COP 21, reiteramos la promesa
de permanecer neutrales en emisiones de carbono.
Esta vez, nos escucharon.
Prestaron atención, les importó.
La diferencia en París fue que los gobiernos se unieron
para aceptar la realidad del cambio climático,
y estuvieron dispuestos a unirse y actuar juntos y trabajar juntos.
Todos los países, desde el muy pequeño hasta el muy grande,
se comprometieron a reducir
las emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero.
La Convención Marco de la ONU sobre el Cambio Climático
dice que si los así llamados compromisos previstos se mantienen,
estaríamos más cerca de contener el calentamiento global
en dos grados centígrados.
Por cierto,
he pedido a los organizadores TED
que suban la temperatura en dos grados aquí,
así que si alguno tiene más calor que lo usual,
ya saben a quién culpar.
Es crucial que todos mantengamos nuestros compromisos.
En lo que respecta a Bután,
mantendremos la promesa de neutralidad en emisiones de carbono.
Estas son algunas maneras en las que lo estamos haciendo.
Proporcionamos electricidad gratis a los agricultores rurales.
La idea es que con electricidad gratis
ya no tendrán que que usar leña para cocinar sus alimentos.
Invertimos en transporte sostenible
y subsidiamos la compra de vehículos eléctricos.
De igual manera, subsidiamos el costo de las luces de LED,
y todo el gobierno trata de dejar el papel.
Estamos limpiando el país con el programa Bután Limpio, un programa nacional,
y estamos plantando árboles en todo el país
mediante Bután Verde,
otro programa nacional.
Pero las zonas protegidas son el elemento clave
de nuestra estrategia de neutralidad de emisiones.
Nuestras zonas protegidas son nuestro sumidero de carbono.
Son nuestros pulmones.
Hoy, más de la mitad del país está protegida,
como parques nacionales, reservas naturales
y santuarios de vida silvestre.
Pero la belleza está en que los conectamos entre sí
mediante una red de corredores biológicos.
Eso significa que los animales son libres de vagar por el país.
Por ejemplo, este tigre.
Fue descubierto a 250 metros sobre el nivel del mar
en las selvas cálidas, subtropicales.
Dos años después, ese mismo tigre
fue descubierto a unos 4000 metros
en nuestras frías montañas.
¿No es impresionante?
(Aplausos)
Debemos mantenerlo así.
Debemos mantener nuestros parques imponentes.
Por eso, cada año separamos recursos
para prevenir la caza furtiva, la minería y la contaminación de parques,
y reservamos otros
para ayudar a las comunidades que viven en esos parques
a gestionar sus bosques,
a adaptarse al cambio climático y a vivir mejor,
mientras siguen en armonía con la Madre Naturaleza.
Pero eso es costoso.
En los próximos años, nuestra pequeña economía no tendrá recursos
para cubrir todos los costos necesarios para proteger nuestro ambiente.
De hecho, cuando hacemos las cuentas,
parece que nos faltan 15 años
hasta poder financiar por completo nuestros esfuerzos de conservación.
Pero ni Bután,
ni el mundo
pueden permitirse pasar 15 años retrocediendo.
Por eso su majestad el rey
creó Bután Por la Vida.
Bután Por la Vida nos da el tiempo necesario.
Nos da un respiro.
Es un mecanismo de financiación
para cuidar de nuestros parques,
para protegerlos,
hasta que el gobierno pueda hacerse cargo por su cuenta plenamente.
La idea es crear un fondo de transición
de donantes particulares, corporaciones e instituciones,
pero el acuerdo solo se cierra
tras cumplir condiciones predeterminadas y comprometer los fondos.
De multiparte a parte simple:
una idea que tomamos de Wall Street.
O sea, los donantes particulares ingresan sin tener que preocuparse
por si quedarán apoyando un plan de fondos insuficientes.
Es como un proyecto de Kickstarter,
solo que con un horizonte de 15 años
y millones de toneladas de dióxido de carbono en juego.
Una vez cerrado el trato,
usamos el fondo de transición para proteger nuestros parques,
y le damos al gobierno el tiempo necesario
para aumentar gradualmente su financiación hasta el fin del período de 15 años.
Luego de eso, nuestro gobierno garantiza financiación para siempre.
Casi lo logramos.
Esperamos cerrar a finales de este año.
Naturalmente, estoy bastante entusiasmado.
(Aplausos)
El Fondo Mundial para la Naturaleza es nuestro socio principal en este viaje,
y quiero expresar mi gran agradecimiento
por el trabajo excelente que hacen en Bután
y en todo el mundo.
(Aplausos)
Puff, está haciendo calor aquí.
Agradezco su atención a nuestra historia,
una historia de cómo cumplimos la promesa de neutralidad de emisiones,
una historia de cómo mantenemos a nuestro país prístino,
para nosotros, nuestros hijos,
para sus hijos y para el mundo.
Pero no estamos aquí para contar historias, ¿no?
Estamos aquí para soñar juntos.
Para terminar, me gustaría compartir otro sueño que tengo.
¿Qué tal si pudiésemos movilizar nuestro liderazgo y recursos,
nuestra influencia y pasión,
para replicar la idea de Bután Por la Vida
en otros países,
para que estos puedan también conservar sus zonas protegidas para siempre?
Después de todo, hay muchos otros países que enfrentan estos mismos problemas.
También tienen recursos naturales
que pueden ayudar a ganar la lucha mundial por la sostenibilidad,
solo que quizá no pueden invertir ahora.
¿Y si establecemos Tierra Por la Vida,
un fondo global, para financiar Bután Por la Vida en el mundo?
Los invito a ayudarme
a llevar este sueño más allá de las fronteras
a todos aquellos que les interese el futuro de nuestro planeta.
Después de todo, estamos aquí para soñar juntos,
para trabajar juntos,
para combatir el cambio climático juntos, para proteger nuestro planeta juntos.
Porque la realidad es
que estamos en esto juntos.
Algunos podemos vestirnos diferente,
pero estamos en esto juntos.
Muchas gracias,
y kadrin chhe la. Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias, gracias, gracias.